what movie did you work with john boyden
it was uh coming up
was coming home are you in touch with
him at all john boyd
no not anymore no it was very sad what
was said
i don't know what happened i don't know
i don't know
i don't know what happened to john you
know we we were pretty close he was my
best
friend among hollywood people and we
both
we won an academy awards together for
coming home
and um he was very very involved with me
and tom hayden in the anti-war work we
were doing
and then he
i don't know he changed into a an
extreme
right winger a birther he was a birther
he is a birther
i guess yes and i just i
you know i didn't know how to connect
with him anymore he's fascinating to me
i don't care
i don't know why huge talent and i knew
you worked with him and i was like well
maybe you can give me insight because
he's like this extreme
right winger could you be friends with a
guy like that now or would be impossible
because
i would think politics would be i
couldn't no
i i couldn't after i mean anybody that
was part of the birther movement i'm
sorry i couldn't
i don't understand how people who are on
opposite ex
extreme opposite positions politically
can live together i just don't know how
they do that well look at this kellyanne
conway yeah kellyanne conway
it's amazing how are they pulling that
off i mean
they'd be killing each other they must
have really good sex
yes it must be the sex that keeps them
together
can sex keep a couple together jane yeah
you better